they were going to talk about numbers in
China and what sort of other minis it
might be associated with I believe the
most famous one would be number eight
it's serious stuff because people are
willing to pay a fortune to get as many
eight on their registration numbers for
their cars on their phone numbers work
out how to have a child on the right
dating the right month with number eight
this is number eight in Arabic numeral
and in Chinese it is just that that was
pretty simple that's pretty simple
that's the simplest one probably people
love it everybody want to be able to
write it so they keep it as simple
number eight is pronounced as bar in
China the pronunciation is very similar
to that of far which means getting
wealthy like tip is five this is bar
this is fun
for example going to see fat hey fast
hey means wish you become really wealthy
doesn't making loads of money doesn't
matter if you become a fat cat so to
encode to dinner to symbolize their wish
to get in wealthy just in a very simple
manner like on their registration
numbers for their account their phone
numbers so they just love to use the
number eight and I have the tenants if I
look a car in the street and pay
attention to the registration number if
there is one with particularly a lot
more number eight than normal cars I
would tend to look at the driver and at
nine of the ten times it would be agent
faced person or Asian person Asian
looking person
sometimes if you like want to book a
particularly a particular table in a
really posh expensive restaurant
I can't want to Table eight or whenever
they get engaged you know and that the
bride-to-be family would expect number
age is involved in a certain way if it
is not they will get upset people are
very much hooked up on a Chinese people
you know we have historically we have
the average people have struggled a lot
you know over thousands of years because
there's almost a straight transition
from a pseudo society a feudal society
to communists to society where always a
large number of population limited
resources everybody wants to become
wealthy important have a new life have a
better life therefore this number aid
kind of symbolize every or not if not
every most Chinese people's dream to
have a good life to have good luck to
have quite a few money in their pocket
yeah you live in England at the moment
yeah do you still have a funny thing
about number eight or have you been
shaken out of what would you use I do
you still find eight special is it
ingrained in you I I'm normally not fund
that much fast buy it but when I go buy
a lottery I said I would have preferred
number eight on it either 8 or 18 20 80
38 as long as there's an a on it is the
number 88 considered especially lucky oh
yeah yeah
888 8080 on 88 if a bride-to-be you know
at the engagement party received 8888
one from the groom-to-be that's very
pleasant and expected very much we also
have another special number which is
associated with good luck and indicate
in associate with offense will happen
smoothly is number six this six in
Chinese character and we also have
traditional Chinese characters which
indicate
which is normally used in very formal
occasion like on on a chair or on a
proper property titled eat which is so
that's the more formal number see yeah
yeah
number six is pronunciation is lil which
is very similar to another Chinese
character indicating good luck which is
Liu Shan six is lil and good luck this
happens smoothly is blue there's the
same yeah that's the same just the tone
is different
normally people like number six to be
involved before we before they go on a
journey before they take a flight they
hope everything would go smoothly when
they go on and a cruise so six leo
really means something everything will
happen or turn out to be fine so there's
no unpleasant surprise involved while
eight number eight far is specifically
associated with getting wealthy you told
me that people in China prefer the
number eight yeah to the number six
yeah does that mean they would rather be
rich than lucky looks like money is the
first priority of people's concern in
China certainly do people in China
realized that 666 is a bad number
no in China that's a very lucky number
okay but they do know that Westerners
don't like it no they are not aware of
that it's a very Western thing about
triple six yeah
yeah there is a number which could be
disliked by a lot of people is number
four
why's that is also because of the
pronunciation number four in Chinese is
pronounced as soup another Chinese word
which means death is pronounced as so
the pronunciation is exactly the same
apart from the tone a simple Chinese
character for four and the traditional
Chinese character for four which is used
in formal occasions like title deed what
does that means that we've used avoided
oh yeah well you try it avoid as much as
possible people would pay for number
eight or six nobody would want to pay
forward them before and then they try it
avoid it as much as possibly can
there's an anecdote here I have
acquaintance who's got six fours in his
phone number when he was trying to phone
up for Chinese delivery and the lady the
Chinese lady on the other side of the
phone would not take his number down the
lady took the first number four was
alright for when it's come to the second
one the lady's voice starts to shake
when it comes to the third one the lady
asked how many other fours you have he's
another three she said I'm not going to
take your order I'm sorry it's just so
unlucky in Chinese culture that was in
the UK was that's in the UK that's
actually Nottingham so if someone in
China had a whole bunch of fours in
their phone number would they get rid of
that phone number oh yeah they would
definitely try if they can yeah they
would complain to the phone shop and
swap to another number yeah
the our member race is 200 okay love is
sick